[Music]
guess what state this is from amanda
texas florida
oh
yeah i got i'm king maker okay sorry
yeah it was florida grasses yeah wyoming
no i already just never get sick i also
guess he's white
oh can we guess more things yeah go
ahead what's the gpa texas wait florida
florida
what happened a white man oh damn he's a
florida man okay what happens to him a
gator bites his balls off no but there
there's a gator in there there's a guy
he's a gator hey we got gator he [ __ ]
the gator giving his four buds no he has
one as a pet no
is it a cute story or a sad one uh a
shocking one we gotta guess tv show
belongs on this youtube show i think
we're still wiping powder
10 videos later we're like [ __ ] [ __ ]
every game you [ __ ] yeah no it's still
the protein it's protein everywhere
made best friends with a gator no
i think we're getting farther away he's
a gator yeah that sounds good give us a
hint okay he's thrust a bone dude he's
trying to teach a a gator his religion
he's a lutheran
he's like yo you need to stop eating
kids and [ __ ] all right
and find jesus banging gators a florida
man dies after going into a lake with
alligators to search for frisbees oh he
deserves it he deserves it i feel like
you should know better living in florida
just get another frisbee yeah you should
right yeah so he jumped in to get a
frisbee and then gators just came he
must be a california transplant there's
a frisbee like a frisbee golf haters
just come i think the gators were there
already and they just go they didn't see
those little eyes you know when the the
when you see gators in the water you see
tiny little eyes just poking outside of
the water sometimes sometimes they're
not even there they blink they go like
this do gators really need those teeth
can we defang all the [ __ ] gators
already can we just how many how many
more people have to die do they need
that skin too i mean we we all need
boots like gators kind of i would love a
pair it looks like gators bite randomly
sometimes
you know when they show well it looks
like they're not aiming like when you
they throw the meat mm-hmm all 60 gators
go oh even though dude their [ __ ]
mouths are here and their eyes are like
here that's the truth
so they can roll over oh yeah once
they've rolled then they got you yeah
they be [ __ ] each other up too yeah i
saw i saw a video where gator this guy
was just [ __ ] sunbathing and another
gator comes out and another gator and
then they just [ __ ] bit his leg and
just started spinning and i was like
dude i know they were cannibalistic like
that hardcore dude gators are the worst
let's just get rid of most of them not
all of them so this guy was just looking
for frisbees yeah so he's just uh
literally decided to search for frisbees
in a lake with surrounding signs warning
people to beware of alligators
i'll be right back keep it in
continue with the story you always keep
in the food was it suicidal no so uh the
police department confirmed uh that a
gator was involved in the death of an
unidentified 47 year old man in uh john
s taylor park the florida fish and
wildlife
club
[Laughter]
conservation commission said a
specialist has been contracted to remove
the gator and efforts will be made to
determine if it was involved in the
situation oh this is one of the
situations where they kill the gator huh
like kill the animal that killed the
dude they didn't kill the animal yet oh
that's good how would you know which
gator harambe thing i like how we get
revenge i do like that
yeah but then they're not even in the
zoo though they're in the wild they're
just doing wild they're in the wild with
signs that say beware of gators
but then if they taste human blood we
have to kind of kill them
because they get too hungry what if
there was another conflicting sign that
said get your own frisbee
oh that's not bad that's a good point
like on the other side of it that's not
bad this is this is this is the whole
you know the disc golfers kind of
situation people play disc golf so what
do you what do you think about disc golf
by the way nick i think it's like you
know honestly i think it's pretty cool
we found the one thing he likes what's
this gal it's it's where they throw the
frisbee into the [ __ ] chains you know
what what are your thighs getting really
warm right now
i don't know what you're talking about
what were you saying can somebody
explain to me what this disc golf thing
is it's literally like golf but throwing
discs
i don't get it i just don't get it what
does it look like so imagine it's like
golf you have a bunch of like those
little holes been said holes are a
little like chain baskets okay okay okay
and then instead of a stick holding a
[ __ ] hitting a ball you throw a
frisbee frisbees as far as you can until
you the least amount of throws to the uh
hole you know what's missing this should
be a shuriken competition
ninja star that would be cool but you
would be changing the sport but the
frisbee it just looks lame then it
wouldn't be just we'll just be throwing
a shirt i got invited uh to play
ultimate frisbee and then have you guys
ever played they sold it to me they said
it was really fun right and then i
watched the game of guys at the park
playing it and i said don't ever invite
me to that [ __ ] ever again [ __ ] you
you know i used to think it was really
whack when i started playing uh ultimate
frisbee with this after school program i
used to work at for with middle
schoolers how old were you at a time of
my life he was probably like 19 years
old right i was like i was like 1920
ultimate frisbee hanging out with
seventh graders wait what makes it
ultimate
it's it's the ultimate sport dude it's
it's why what's different from just
throwing it around what's the ultimate
because there's a there's a throwing it
around is like okay whatever but then
when you're trying to run it into an end
zone and you're trying to pass it to the
home oh that's what you're trying to do
yeah so it's like football it's kind of
like football it's kind of like
it's it's it's rugby but just a little
more gay i'm starting a fund i'm putting
five thousand dollars into it to start
the fund where every time somebody says
and then i started playing ultimate
frisbee somebody punches them in the
[ __ ] face i like i'll invest into
that yeah five i want i'm doing five i
don't play stupid sports yeah that's me
too
i don't play dumb [ __ ] yeah contributes
what about spike ball you guys play
spike ball i never played okay yeah you
never play spike ball was it like
volleyball but it's all spikes no it's
it's the little black and yellow net
thing and then it's literally you go to
the beach with it and then everybody
literally spiking the ball into the net
and then you just playing i only see
like white college boys
oh cool it's actually kind of fun i also
thought it looked very stupid oh yeah i
know what i know you're talking about
now yeah it's pretty [ __ ] cool i only
play real manly [ __ ] like jiu jitsu hey
you guys ever played badminton low-key
that game fire really fun my boyfriend
won't let me do jiu jitsu why not i
wanted to but he says he doesn't like
the idea of like men choke me out for an
hour does it have to be men do jiu-jitsu
like any sort of progression i'm just
going to go there and get choked for an
hour i want him to watch me and nick
roll around
very hard for two hours straight
non-stop super sweaty
choking each other out super manly we
have we have a friend that we train with
a training partner her name is justine
she [ __ ] me up she is like this little
like
very unassuming asian girl yeah she's
not little dude she's bigger than me jiu
jitsu is the one that eddie bravo does
right yeah yeah is she okay you trained
with her can you train with a girl i
mean i don't know i think he like is not
pro anyone else choking me oh
it's because it's kind of a kink though
it's not a sexual thing he knows it's
not like it's not a sexual is it an
actual kink of yours yes then i
understand and that's a sexual thing
that would place him that's everybody's
though
for sexual reasons i want to do jiu
jitsu because it looks like i
you get into those understand and
suddenly your kink turns on you're like
[ __ ] that's a funny that's quote i don't
want to do jiu jitsu for sexual reasons
i do i do i do exactly what nick does
like nicki is super indigenous
nikki's super into getting credit carded
so but if i knew
if i knew that she was going to go to a
[ __ ] place and get credit card the
whole time i understand
yeah if i knew that she was going to the
bank today no way
what bank does it when you sign up what
the [ __ ] what bank
[ __ ]
thank you please swipe your cards for
banking with us she loves it that's her
favorite so yeah i always i always like
to do that does she pretend like she's
not into it when it happens
like stop like the opposite reaction
don't ever do that again
[Laughter]
oh that's it that was the perfect level
dude
i'm like oh it says hang on nope it says
insert you know what i mean nowadays you
gotta just keep the chip in yeah
where is it that's so funny so why don't
you credit card to me anymore it's
because we do tap now
because we just use venmo
time's changed double click on our phone
about three minutes into this bit she's
usually just like i'm a [ __ ] person
and i'm like oh yeah okay sorry sorry
three minutes a long time [ __ ] well she
has a big ass so she doesn't always know
when i'm playing with it yeah yeah
not really oh okay
do you world series of poker
i haven't yet
i haven't yet thank you for hearing me
with that one there you go
i enjoyed it
what was that all right nick no no no no
no
i don't i forgot the whole guy
the gator the guy died credit card
again all right lesson here you guys
started hating on frisbees it went to a
whole different conversation start a
gator with a frisbee lesson here kids do
not try to
you do not try to [ __ ] insert a
credit card in the anus of a gator there
it is where is the anus of a gator
though do they have anuses
don't know do they have anuses they
gotta have something right lesson is
play real sports play real sports play
real sports don't admit on a youtube
show that you like ultimate frisbee
ultimate
[Music]
oh
[Music]